[Music]
now time for the man you've all been
waiting for the king of the high street
you've been described as the
unacceptable face of capitalism I've
done nothing wrong
[Music]
this is Nick he's chronically by life
just loves money he peed himself on his
wife 1.2 billion Pope this is for all of
you you're the fashion editor yes just
at least look a bit more like a model
before start you look great it was his
own learn from the start what is the
average weight in Sri Lanka 50 P and day
imagine how many dresses I can get made
there's a bully not you had to shape my
it it's a parasite its Korsak types
avoidance go away look at that you got
by a view like that oh wait no I have
we've been working this party for over a
year he wants it to repair his
reputation it's all about image
the to PR at the model it's all part of
a brand how bad is it
you know I've read the mail online is
cleavage clickbait yeah they said I'm
the tip this time
[Music]
Antoninus now maybe it's sharing the
nose you even get doubles quick question
I know your mind the look-alikes
yeah Simon Cowell these good yeah yeah
looks like what Stuart it's her older
brother George Michael Jordan or cousin
Ted you stop staring we please it's very
off-putting
or noise I'm in the business of loud
why have you got a lion we recreate in
Gladiator
[Music]
that's fuchsia yeah fuchsia you should
spit in your faces I want in your face I
am in your face
you